guten Abend willkommen zu ZDF heute live
seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges war angezel mehrere Male
schon in der Ukraine er hat dort mit den
Menschen sprechen können er hat ihre
Schicksale gezeigt und er ist auch
selbst in bedrohliche Situationen
geraten er hat gezeigt wie russische
Soldaten ein Zivilisten erschießen ein
Kriegsverbrechen hat gentzel ist freier
Journalist der auch für das ZDF arbeitet
insbesondere für Frontal 21 heute Abend
können wir mit ihm sprechen und später
noch mit dem Militärexperten oberstad
Wolfgang Richter von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik ihr könnt
beiden gerne eure Fragen und eure
Kommentare schicken das tut ihr am
besten indem wir uns einfach eine Mail
schickt an die Adresse die er jetzt
eingeblendet seht oder ihr schreibt eure
Kommentare und Fragen einfach in die
Kommentarspalten ich werde sie gerne für
Euch weitergeben jetzt erst in die
Ukraine zu abendinsel
guten Abend
hallo guten Abend du bist gerade in
einer Unterkunft für geflüchtete in Rake
treffen wir dich an das ist ja die
zweitgrößte Stadt des Landes wo es in
den vergangenen 24 Stunden wieder luft-
ja aktuell ist es sehr ruhig wie gesagt
wir sind in einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft
die Kinder hinter mir die stammen
überwiegend aus Dörfern östlich der
Stadt also sehr nah an der russischen
Grenze die haben Schlimmes erlebt für
die ist jetzt natürlich ja das Leben
hier in der Flüchtlingsunterkunft
erstmal eine Auszeit von dem was sie in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten erlebt
haben
tatsächlich ist es
sehr sehr bewegend die Kinder im
Hintergrund zu sehen weil man auch meint
ihn ansehen zu können was sie in den
letzten Wochen erlebt haben müssen was
erzählen die dir
ja also
viele Kinder sagen gar nicht so viel
sondern man hat erlebt als die hier
ankamen das waren sehr blasse sehr
versteinerte sehr ernste Gesichter
mittlerweile hat sich das verändert sie
finden langsam Vertrauen auch zu ja zu
zu fremden
Personen
sie reden gar nicht so viel darüber
viele sagen ja Krieg bedeutet vor allen
Dingen dass es laut ist das Granaten
fliegen manche Kinder können
unterscheiden sogar zwischen ja zwischen
Beschuss der rausgeht aus einem Dorf und
oder reinkommt ob es gefährlich oder
weniger gefährlich ist wir haben gestern
in zirkonie das ist ein Ort der liegt
etwa fünf Kilometer von haakev entfernt
Kinder angetroffen die sitzen quasi seit
Kriegsbeginn im Keller
und
ja also das war sehr bewegend die zu
sehen die dachten erstmal wir sind
Soldaten weil wir natürlich ankamen mit
Helm und mit Westen bis die Eltern
versucht haben den zu erklären dass wir
Journalisten sind und dass das was wir
hier machen letztlich die Zuschauer in
Deutschland sehen werden du hast es
gerade angesprochen du warst in zirkonie
dass es etwa 20 km von der russischen
Grenze entfernt und dieses Dorf konnte
die ukrainische Armee jetzt
zurückerobern nach mehr als 70 Tagen
unter russischer Besatzung eben dein
Bericht wird heute Abend bei Frontal 21
gezeigt aber wir schauen uns jetzt schon
mal einen Auszug daraus an
wir sind unterwegs von hakif Richtung
russische Grenze ganz nah an der Front
doch dann geht es plötzlich nicht mehr
weiter
die Russen Feuer in unsere Richtung wir
nehmen einen Umweg und erreichen unser
Ziel
ich bin in zirkonie einem Dorf ganz nah
5 km von hakif entfernt von hier hat die
russische Armee über Wochen die Stadt
beschossen mit Artillerie wika zeigt uns
wo sie Schutz gesucht haben 74 Tage lang
lebte die neunjährige mit ihrer Familie
in diesem Keller
da hat einer geschlafen und da haben
fünf Leute geschlafen und hier noch ein
anderer
was mir fehlt Frieden und meine Freunde
ich vermisse jetzt sogar die Schule
Vika und die anderen Kinder können jetzt
wieder draußen spielen
dieses Ehepaar hatte seine Einfahrt für
die russischen Soldaten beschriftet hier
leben Menschen
Nacht sind die Soldaten betrunken durchs
Dorf gezogen haben auf Fenster
geschossen und sein Haus angezündet wir
sind zum Nachbarn gegangen um zu gucken
ob er noch lebt wir haben ihn gefunden
er wurde erschossen
im Dorf sind die Wasserleitung zerstört
Strom erzeugt ein Generator und Gas gibt
es nicht Alexandra filatova ist trotzdem
glücklich
endlich Freiheit ich bin so glücklich
und ich habe mein Enkelkind
wir verlassen zirkonie vorbei an den
Trümmern russischer Panzer die
ukrainische Armee hat das Gebiet
zurückerobert doch immer noch gibt es
russische Angriffe
und wenn man diese Bilder sieht muss man
davon ausgehen dass es in zirkonie
möglicherweise ähnliche Royal Taten
gegeben hat wie wen Butter das ist ans
Licht kommen wird
also was uns die Einwohner erzählt haben
das sind eben die haben uns berichtet
von Plünderungen die haben uns berichtet
dass die Menschen nicht aus der Stadt
aus dem Dorf raussdorften sie durften
nur Richtung Russland fliehen wir haben
von der Erschießung eines Nachbarn
erfahren der im Keller wohl getötet
worden sei von betrunkenen russischen
Soldaten was ihr bis jetzt nicht
erfahren haben das ist das ist
irgendwelche Massengräber gibt oder
Liquidierung wie in Butcher
beispielsweise bei Kiew davon haben wir
bis jetzt noch nichts erfahren und sie
haben vereinzelt auch geflüchtete hier
in der Flüchtlingsunterkunft berichtet
dass junge Männer verschleppt werden
auch das haben wir erfahren aber von
Massentötung ist uns bislang nichts
bekannt
du sagst gerade dass Männer verschleppt
wurden das
US-Verteidigungsministerium hat eben
Hinweise auch darauf dass Menschen
zwangsweise aus der Ukraine nach
Russland gebracht werden und die
ukrainische
Menschenrechtsbeauftragte des Parlaments
spricht von 1,9 Millionen das sind
natürlich Zahlen die wir nicht
überprüfen können aber wie vermehrt hast
du das in letzter Zeit gehört und wo
kommen diese Menschen hin das ist auch
eine Frage die uns hier gestellt wurde
ja das ist eine berechtigte Frage aber
wenn man das ist ja genau das Problem
wenn man hier mit den Menschen in der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft beispielsweise
spricht die sagen wir wissen nicht wo
der Junge unseres Nachbarn
beispielsweise ist wir haben noch
gesehen dass der Probleme hatte mit mit
russischen Soldaten die haben den halt
mit mitgenommen und dann ist er nicht
mehr aufgetaucht sie haben bis heute
nichts von den erfahren es gibt Gerüchte
das muss man sagen dass sie teilweise
zur Zwangsarbeit also gezwungen werden
beispielsweise Schützengräben auszuheben
aber das sind halt Gerüchte vielfach
weiß man nicht wo sie sind und wie
gesagt diese Verschleppung davon haben
wir immer wieder gehört auch in den in
den Dörfern aber
wo diese jungen Männer geblieben sind
und Jugendlichen das wissen wir nicht
Leben unter russischer Besatzung war für
die Menschen dort irgendeine Art von
Alltag möglich oder haben die sich jetzt
wochenlang in ihren Kellern verstecken
müssen
also das war alles weil alles weit weg
von Alltag speziell jetzt gestern in
Symphonie die Menschen beispielsweise
die wurden gezwungen also zumindest ist
uns das erzählt worden von ihm selbst
dass sie nicht aus dem Bunkern nicht
rauskommen durften das was wir da
gesehen haben gestern dass die Menschen
unter freiem Himmel kochen das war
völlig neu ich dachte anfangs ja das
haben die auch schon vorher so gemacht
nein das war eine neue Situation dass
sie raus durften überhaupt raus durften
aus den
sie hatten keinen Strom kein Gas das was
sie an Strom hatten das zogen sie aus
Autobatterien die haben sie uns auch
gestern gezeigt also das war alles
andere als als Alltag jetzt muss er noch
dazu sagen dass speziell aus zirkonie
wurde auch hartes geschossen die
Artillerie hat von da aus auf die Stadt
gezielt und hat die Stadt systematisch
quasi mit Beschuss unter Beschuss
genommen
mittlerweile ist die russische Armee
abgezogen und es hat natürlich für Haken
ganz großen Vorteil es ist etwas ruhiger
geworden aber für die Menschen in der in
der Zeit der Besatzung war dort kein
alltägliches Leben möglich und was ist
jetzt was ist mit Infrastruktur
medizinischer Versorgung können die
Kinder wieder in die Schule wie läuft
das Leben dort wieder an
also zirkulie ist immer noch weit weg
vom Alltag also wir hatten gestern dort
immer noch erlebt dass in Teilen des
Ortes
Artillerie zu hören war auch Explosion
dass das ist bis jetzt nicht vorbei ich
hatte erst gerade noch mal mit einem
Kollegen gesprochen der heute dort war
der mir ebenfalls berichtet hat dass da
nach wie vor
Kämpfe statt zwischen finden zwischen
russischen und ukrainischen Soldaten
da ist ja es kommt freiwillige
mittlerweile mit Lebensmitteln in diesen
Ort aber der Ort ist noch weit weg von
Normalität und wir sehen immer noch
Menschen die rausfahren aus dieser aus
diesem Dorf und versuchen sich hier in
Sicherheit zu bringen in hake
man hat am Ende des Tages einfach keine
Vorstellung wie es den Menschen dort
geht du hast mit ihnen gesprochen wie
wie schwer sind diese Traumatisierungen
also der erste Tag hier in dieser
Unterkunft als wir das erste Mal hier
waren und besprochen haben mit
geflüchteten auch mit das sind
vereinigen Mütter mit ihren Kindern die
hier angekommen sind
das war
also da da war spätestens nach 30
Sekunden begann die Frauen an zu weinen
das war permanent so dass die Erinnerung
an das was dort passiert ist sehr
schwerwiegen sie kriegen hier
psychologische Betreuung wir hatten dann
auch mit der Therapeutin gesprochen die
sagte das fällt selbst ihr schwer sich
das anhören zu müssen und sie trägt das
ganze mit nach Hause und das ist auch
für sie sehr nachhaltig was sie von den
Menschen hier hört
Barbara fragt auf Youtube die Kinder die
bei dir im Hintergrund sind die
beschäftigen sie sie möchte wissen ob
die alleine sind oder ob die Eltern
dabei sind
nein die Kinder hinter mir die haben
alle ihre Mütter mitgebracht
die sind jetzt nicht die stehen hier
auch im Raum irgendwo mit aber die sind
nicht alleine geflüchtet sondern die
sind mit ihren ja mit ihren Müttern ja
Richtung aufgebrochen sind dann
teilweise auf abenteuerliche Weise von
Freiwilligen abgeholt worden das
teilweise unfassbar es gibt da eine Frau
beispielsweise ich weiß nicht ob man sie
sieht sie ist zwei Tage mit ihr mit
ihren fünf Kindern durch den Wald
marschiert bis sie bis sie raus war aus
den russisch gesetzten Gebieten
es ist unvorstellbar was die Menschen da
gerade erleben die internationale
Organisation von Migration sagt heute
das insgesamt fast 14 Millionen Menschen
in der Ukraine ihre Heimatorte verlassen
haben gleichzeitig hören wir aber auch
zunehmend von Frauen die mit ihren
Kindern wieder zurückkommen
du hast auch einige getroffen warum
gehen diese Menschen diesen Schritt
naja das ist die Lage ist ja recht
unterschiedlich in der Ukraine
in Kiew wir waren bevor wir nach hakif
gereist sind waren wir wieder in Kiew
gewesen dort ist die Situation wirklich
sehr ruhig seit dem Abzug der russischen
Truppen es gab immer mal wieder
Raketenbeschuss aber es ist relativ
ruhig dass der eine Punkt der andere ist
dass die Frauen natürlich auch zu ihren
Männern zurück wollen und sobald sich da
eine Möglichkeit ergibt wollen die als
Familie wieder weiterleben und ihre
Zukunft gestalten das ist ein ganz
normale Situation niemand ist gerne
getrennt also und ja jeder will als
Familie existieren
wir haben hier noch eine Frage sag mal
wenn du in der Ukraine zum Drehen bist
wir müssen wir uns das vorstellen wie
schaffst du es dich dort einigermaßen
sicher zu bewegen
ja wir ich bin ja nicht allein also wir
haben noch ein Kollegen der uns
begleitet beispielsweise der der ist aus
haglift der kennt die Region sehr genau
wir beobachten jeden Tag wie sich die
Frontlinien verändern versuchen auch
nicht wirklich bis ans äußerte Äußerste
zu gehen
und ja wir schützen uns mit Westen wir
haben die immer in unserer Nähe wir
haben Helme man sieht es auch hier
vielleicht im Bild
aber klar es bleibt immer ein Restrisiko
dass sich nicht ausschließen lässt
und wer sind ja live auf Facebook und
auch auf YouTube und da gibt es
teilweise
Vorwürfe dass die Kinder die bei dir
jetzt im Hintergrund in der Unterkunft
sind dass das jetzt quasi eine
Inszenierung sei vielleicht kannst du
das kurz erklären damit wir das richtig
stellen können
nee wir sind wie gesagt wir sind hier in
der in der Flüchtlingsunterkunft und die
hatten einfach Lust zuzugucken und warum
soll für ich finde das ganz in Ordnung
und
es sind ja diejenigen über die wir hier
reden und ich glaube das ist auch völlig
in Ordnung dass die Eltern stehen ja
auch mit dabei
dass die Menschen auch im Gesicht und
eine Identität bekommen und vielleicht
ist es auch einfach eine
kleine Abwechslung für die Kinder die ja
im Moment wirklich nicht so sehr viel
machen können
und wie geht es dir bei deinen
drehreisen hast du da auch manchmal
Angst
ja
also zu sagen dass man keine Angst hat
dass das wäre Gladbeck gelogen natürlich
haben wir Angst wenn heute sind wir eine
Situation geraten wo auch wieder ein Ort
beschossen wurde wir waren ins Latino
das ist etwa 19 km von der russischen
Grenze entfernt
[Musik]
da sitzt man dann eben in einem Keller
zeitweise und man man spürt wie wie der
Boden vibriert unter unter den unter den
Einschlägen im Ort und man konzentriert
sich und hofft die ganze Zeit dass es
sich näher kommt also ja wir haben Angst
klar das ist so
und ich danke dir sehr für deinen
Schilderungen und ich sag's auch noch
mal gerne die ganze Reportage von dir
gibt es jetzt gleich um 9 Uhr bei
Frontal 21 und ich möchte dir zum
Abschied noch zwei Kommentare Vorlesen
Nils schreibt auf Facebook ich finde es
gut und wichtig dass Arndt Genzel vor
Ort ist und uns eindrücklich von dem
grauen berichtet dem die ukrainische
Bevölkerung durch Putins Angriffskrieg
ausgesetzt ist vielen Dank dafür lieber
Arndt und noch und schreibt auf Youtube
vielen Dank dass ihr nicht müde werdet
dieses Grauen weiter zu dokumentieren
Herr Genzel soll bitte auf sich
aufpassen mit den Worten möchte ich mich
verabschieden alles Gute vielen Dank
tschüss danke
ja wie gesagt 21 Uhr Frontal 21 und bis
dahin ist noch ein bisschen Zeit deshalb
wollen wir gleich mit dem
Militärexperten oberstad
wolfgang-richter sprechen guten Abend
guten Abend
hat gestern gesagt dass russlands
Präsident Putin keinen Ausweg aus dieser
Krise weiß könnt ihr das den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf Schwächen oder macht es
die Sache dann vielleicht sogar noch
gefährlicher weil unberechenbarer
ja zunächst einmal müssen wir festhalten
dass die erste Phase der russischen
Operationen ja gescheitert ist vor Kiew
mit der hohen Verlusten großen Fehlern
den man gemacht hat diese Fehler lagen
im Grunde genommen an der politischen
Führung selbst denn es war ja Putin der
die parola ausgegeben hat das eine
Identität der Ukraine nicht vorhanden
ist und dass die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit also nicht sehr
stark entwickelt wäre das hat sich als
ein großer Trugschluss erwiesen und die
ganzen Fehler die dann gemacht waren
waren sozusagen die Folgefehler davon
russland versucht jetzt das zu vermeiden
es hat sich konzentriert das bildet
jetzt operative Schwerpunkte ist sucht
ein Gelände in dem die russischen
Strukturen auch besser wirken können
im flachen Gelände also zwischen ishium
und Lugansk und da haben sie vielleicht
mehr Aussichten auf Erfolg mit ihren
Strukturen allerdings in der Kampfmoral
und auch in der taktischen
Fähigkeit haben sich die Ukraine bisher
als überlegen erwiesen und das scheint
jetzt auch in der Phase 2 wieder
sozusagen ein dass es nur sehr sehr Ziel
vorangeht für die Russen und das ist
also eher vorwärts und dann auch mal
wieder Rückwärtsbewegung gibt aber die
operative Linie sich nicht wesentlich
verändert natürlich könnte Putin jetzt
sagen naja immerhin wir haben den
Korridor gesichert zwischen der Creme
und dem dornbuz und wir haben auch
westlich der Kremmen bis zum raumkreis
an Erfolge gehabt wir werden sehen wie
diese Rückzüge von
Schalke dann aussehen werden ob man da
auch noch im Südosten oder Nordosten
muss ich von hier aus jetzt sagen mit
Blick auf die Karte doch noch Gebiete
sichern kann aber das sind ja im
Verhältnis zum ersten narrativ
bescheidener Erfolge aber es liegt bei
Putin zu interpretieren was ein Sieg ist
was ein Erfolg ist wir werden er denn
eher immerhin haben wir die Creme und
den don-bass gesichert oder eine
potenzielle Gefahr für Russland
abgewehrt wie auch immer man wir das im
Westen wir werden würden dann kann er
das so interpretieren die Deutung Soheit
hatte ja innerhalb Russlands also daran
soll es nicht scheitern die Frage ist
aber und die hat sich aus der Rede nicht
ergeben was für Kriegsziele er denn
jetzt verfolgt und wie das operativ
weitergehen soll da sind wir nicht
schlauer als wir vor seiner Rede waren
und ich habe die Befürchtung dass die
Fragen von Friedensverhandlungen und der
Konditionen dafür derzeit auf dem
Gefechtsfeld entschieden werden und
nicht durch die Bereitschaft zu
Kompromissen
sie haben es gerade angesprochen die
Rede von Präsident Putin gestern
anlässlich des Tages des Sieges über
Nazi-Deutschland im Zweiten Weltkrieg es
gab bei diesem Militärparade dann hat
Präsident Putin die Rede gehalten wir
hören noch mal kurz rein Putin hat den
Don Bass im Osten Latten des Landes ja
sehr hervorgehoben
die NATO-Länder wollten uns nicht hören
das heißt dass sie ihn Wirklichkeit ganz
andere Pläne hatten ganz offensichtlich
haben sie eine weitere Operation im
don-bass vorbereitet sie haben
beabsichtigt in unser Territorium
inklusive der Krim einzudringen ich
möchte mich nun an unsere Streitkräfte
richten und an das volksherr von Don
Bass sie kämpfen für die Heimat für ihre
Zukunft dafür dass niemand die Lehren
des Zweiten Weltkriegs vergisst
die us-geheimdienstchefin häns sagt
heute dass der Krieg wahrscheinlich auch
mit der Eroberung des dombas nicht zum
Ende kommen würde wie sehen Sie das
kann natürlich sein das hängt jetzt
wirklich von der politischen Führung in
Moskau ab was man dort als Kriegsziel
ausgibt und wie viele Ressourcen man
noch verwenden will um diesen Krieg zu
einem erfolgreichen Ende zu führen mit
den gegenwärtigen Ressourcen dürfte das
allerdings schwierig werden weil die
russischen Streitkräfte jetzt schon
strategisch überdehnt sind ich meine
hier nicht nur die Ukraine als solche
sondern insgesamt das große russische
Territorium muss ja an vielen Stellen
gehalten werden oder zumindest man muss
bereits in der Bereitschaft sein
bestimmte Flanken zu spritzen wenn sie
mal von Romanski wo die Nordflotte also
auch die atomar bewaffnete Flotte steht
runtergehen bis zu den grenzen
unmittelbar an der NATO also im
Baltischen Bereich oder in den Kaukasus
wo es immer schon schwierigkeiten gab
und Unruhen und dasselbe trifft zu für
Zentralasien und dann können Sie ganz
nach Osten gehen in den fernen Osten wo
auf den Kurilen mittlerweile Russland
auch sich gegenüber den japanischen
Ansprüchen auf die korelen
wahrscheinlich deswegen haben wir auch
viele geglaubt Putin würde gestern bei
der Rede die generalmobil machen
verkünden die eben in die Lage versetzt
hätte mehr Rekruten einzuziehen
Reservisten einzuziehen und die
Kriegswirtschaft oder die Wirtschaft auf
eine Kriegswirtschaft hin zu trennen er
hat es nicht getan aber es ist ja noch
nicht vom Tisch das kann ja alles noch
kommen und insofern wissen wir nicht wie
weit ergehen will um diesen Krieg bis zu
einem gewissen Ende zu führen wir werden
natürlich schlauer wenn wir wüssten wo
denn eigentlich die möglichen
Kompromisslinien sind und was die
eigentlichen kriegszelle sind von
Russland und das wissen wir im Moment
nicht und deswegen sind wir etwas im
spekulativen Bereich meine Befürchtung
ist dass der Kompromiss dort entstehen
wird wo der Krieg seinen Ausgang war
nämlich mit der Behauptung denn das des
dornbas möglicherweise der Krems und mit
der Behauptung man habe eine drohende
Gefahr abgewehrt weil der Präsident
selenski hat ja schon im März gesagt er
würde auf dem NATO-Beitritt verzichten
wollen und hat seinen Schwerpunkt auf
den EU-Beitritt gelegt wenn da am Ende
eine Kompromisslinie entsteht dann kann
ich nur sagen warum bedurfte ist dann so
viele Tote so viele zerstörter Städte
und so vielen
Ausgangslage
zurückzukehren und die dann als Erfolg
zu verbuchen sie haben eben die general
mobil machen angesprochen die ja gestern
ausgeblieben ist Marto fragt ob sie denn
dennoch von einer mobil machen in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen ausgehen
also zumindest würde ich das jetzt nicht
ausschließen das kann natürlich
passieren dass es so eine Mobilmachung
noch geben wird das ist ja eben sehr
abhängig von den Kriegszielen die man
verfolgt aber wenn ich mir ansehe ich
meine Putin hat seine eigene ratio aber
er ist ein rational denkender Mensch und
er wird sicher abwägen was für Vorteile
die weitere Kriegsführung Ihnen bringen
wird auch politische Vorteile auch
innenpolitische Vorteile und wo er die
Ressourcen so erschöpft dass am Ende die
innenpolitische Lage sich auch gegen ihn
wendet das darf man ja nicht ganz
vergessen
insofern wir sind im Bereich der
Spekulation wir wissen es nicht der
Krieg kann zum Stillstand kommen wegen
Erschöpfung bei der Seiten zu einem
abnutzungskrieg
auch ein Durchbruch wäre nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen wahrscheinlich oft tut
den noch darauf
ich denke aber dass die Ukraine
mittlerweile gefestigt
und motiviert genug sind um auch
taktisch versiert genug sind um auch
dagegen Mittel zu finden so dass ich
eher von einem abnutzungskrieg ausgeht
der allerdings dann noch lange dauern
könnte dazu gibt es auch noch eine Frage
von Pera hat die Ukraine mit
Waffenlieferungen eine echte Aussicht
auf eine erfolgreiche Verteidigung und
Wiedereroberung bzw Befreiung
also die Ukraine war nie eine schwache
Armee das ist glaube ich eine
Fehleinschätzung schon immer gewesen
sie war die zweitstärkste Armee in
Europa wenn ich die Türkei mal nicht
dazu zähle vor schon 2014 das Problem
damals war es ja nicht dass die Armee
schwach war sondern dass sie nicht
motiviert war das ist auch leicht
erklärbar da die beiden Armeen die
russische und die ukrainische aus der
gleichen sowjetischen Armee
hervorgegangen sind ist sehr viele
familiäre Beziehungen gab sehr viele
Bekanntschaften manche russische
Soldaten blieben in der ukrainischen
Armee weil sie eben dort stationiert
waren und umgekehrt auch Ukrainer in
Moskau die ich selber dort auch
getroffen habe in russischen Uniformen
so dass es eigentlich schwer vorstellbar
dass solche bruderarmeen aufeinander
schießen würden und so kam es dann auch
2014 ein Teil des übergelaufen ein Teil
hat er keine Lust zu kämpfen und man hat
im wesentlichen sich auf freiwilligen
Bata abgestützt um den Kampf dann im
Donbass zu führen und das ist dann auch
bis dem gewissen gerade gelungen nur die
Situation ist heute eine völlig andere
wir sind jetzt acht Jahre weiter in der
Zwischenzeit hat sich die ukrainische
Identität erheblich gefestigt und
gestärkt der verteidigungswille ist da
die Bevölkerung steht hinter der Armee
und das ist gerade zu bewundernswert die
Russland auf vielen Bevölkerungsteile
sind wir auch dann eben eher im auf der
Krim zu suchen oder in den Teilen des
dombas die schon unter der Kontrolle der
Volksrepubliken waren so dass also
vielleicht auch hier der Grund zu sehen
war warum Putin sich so verschätzt hat
in dem
widerstandswellen der Ukraine das ist
eine erstaunliche Entwicklung
denn eigentlich hätte es der
Geheimdienst besser wissen müssen
denn die sind ja in der Regel auch gut
informiert warum ist da ein anderes kam
eine schwer zu sagen aber das kann daran
liegen dass der engste Zirkel der
Entscheider umfooting herum eben nicht
mehr zugänglich war für die anderen
Berater die es im Umfeld gibt und da
gibt es ja viele vernünftige Leute auch
in der Akademie
ehemalige Generäle ehemalige Diplomaten
die auch davor genannt haben sie wurden
nicht mehr gehört und das ist wohl der
Grund für diese Fehleinschätzung die
sich dann nach unten fortgesetzt hat sie
haben gerade den Widerstandswillen der
Ukrainer angesprochen und da gibt es ein
Beispiel lassen Sie uns noch kurz über
die Schlangeninsel sprechen die gilt ja
als strategisch wichtig im Schwarzen
Meer und seit einigen Wochen ist sie ja
besetzt von den russischen Truppen hier
sehen wir auf der Karte wo sich diese
Schlangeninsel befindet nämlich im
Schwarzen Meer nun versucht ja die
Ukraine offenbar diese Insel zurück zu
erobern diese Bilder sollen einen
Angriff auf einen russischen
Hubschrauber zeigen und auch gestern
soll es erneut eine größere
landungsaktion gegeben haben bisher ohne
Erfolg das sagt die russische Seite
was sagen diese Bilder aus und warum ist
diese kleine Insel dann so wichtig
also zunächst mal die Insel liegt etwa
12 Seen malen vor der Küste der Ukraine
und Rumäniens ziemlich genau an der See
Grenzlinie zwischen den beiden Ländern
deswegen war die Insel auch lange Zeit
zwischen Rumänien und der Ukraine
umstritten erst 2003 haben die hat einen
haben sie sich darauf geeinigt dass
diese Insel also in der Tat Ukrainisch
ist und es gab dann noch später ein
schiedspruch des international sehr
Gerichtshof wo ist denn nun genau die
Grenzen des Festlands es gibt denn das
ist entscheidend für die
Gas und Ölvorkommen die dort vermutet
werden und wenn man die Insel also in
der Hand hat dann ergeben sich daraus
auch solche Ansprüche damals ging das zu
80% etwa für Rumänien ausgeführt und so
20 Prozent für die Ukraine trotzdem ist
der Festland Sockel natürlich von
Bedeutung wenn man später dort mal Gas
und Öl schaffen will das ist der eine
Punkt der andere ist der militärische
Punkt wie die Entfernung schon sagt sie
ist sehr nah an indikatorland nämlich
Rumänien und sie steht südlich des
Bezirks Odessa und wenn man eine Linie
zieht von der Schlangeninsel zur Krim
dann ist das genau die Blockade Linie
zum auf der zum Beispiel auch der
Kreuzer Moskau stand das heißt von dort
wird blockiert einerseits dass der
Handel der Ukraine nicht mehr über das
Schwarze Meer kommt weder Export noch
Import und zum anderen wird von dieser
Linie aus aufgeklärt dort stehen
Radarstation und elektronische
Einrichtungen und zum dritten werden
auch von dieser Linie von Schiffen und
Raketen gefeuert auf Odessa und die
umliegenden Depots oder
Verbindungslinien also insofern hat
diese Insel eine große Bedeutung was wir
jetzt gehört haben über die Angriffe der
Ukrainer offenbar ging es um eine
kombinierte see- und Luftlandung wenn
man der russischen Seite jetzt Glauben
schenkt dann ist dieser Angriff
gescheitert die Ukrainer werden
naturgemäß sagen wie viele
Geräte sie auf der russischen Seite
vernichtet haben mein Eindruck derzeit
ist wenn wir nicht morgen bessere
Informationen bekommen dass dieser
Versuch eine kombinierten luft- und
Seelandung tatsächlich gescheitert ist
aber es zeigt dass die Ukraine immer
noch in der Lage sind auch zu sehen und
über die Luftstreitkräfte doch erheblich
Operationen auszuführen
wir haben zum Schluss noch eine
spannende Frage von Jack Beats auf
Youtube Herr Richter wie schätzen Sie
den Einfluss von Drohnen in Bezug auf
Aufnahmen Granaten Abwürfe auf diesen
Krieg ein betrifft das vor allem die
Moral russischer Soldaten
also ich glaube es betrifft in erster
Linie mal die die taktischen Fähigkeiten
und die Effizienz mit der die Ukraine
den Krieg führen ich sprach vorhin schon
mal von der vom taktischen geschickt und
Sie stimmen ihre Artillerie ihre
Panzerabwehr und ihre Drohnenangriffe
sehr exakt aufeinander ab es ist eben
zum Beispiel vor Kiew gelungen in dieser
langen Verbindungslinien die die langen
LKW und und Fahrzeugkolonnen mit
Gegenangriffen hineinzufahren sie mit
Artillerie zunächst zu blockieren
teilweise auch durch Sprengung von
Brücken und anschließend diese
blockierten Fahrzeuge anzugreifen mit
Kampfdrohnen aber auch mit Artillerie
auch mit mehrfach Raketenwerfern und in
der Abstimmung dieser Waffen Wahnsinn
weitaus gescheckter als die Russen ich
warne nur davor auf einem
wunderwaffensystem immer zu setzen das
ist die kampfdrohne hat natürlich eine
erhebliche Bedeutung aber die
eigentliche Bedeutung wird dann
Niedersachsen wenn man es versteht sie
im Gefecht verbundener war auf ein
taktisch korrekt einzusetzen das heißt
die einzelnen Waffensysteme die ich
gerade genannt habe so aufeinander
abzustimmen dass sie den besten
synergetischen Effekts zeigen
ich danke Ihnen sehr herzlich dass sie
sich heute Abend für uns Zeit genommen
haben Oberst Adi Richter noch einen
guten Abend tschüss
und ich danke auch euch für eure Fragen
für eure Kommentare und durchaus auch
danke für die kritischen denn das ist
wichtig dass wir darüber reden wir
konnten ja einiges klarstellen Peter Z
hat uns auf Youtube auch geschrieben
okay danke für die Klarstellung
bezüglich der Kinder man muss es
ansprechen dann kann man es klären danke
euch danke fürs dabei sein bis dann
tschüss